e eu observo vou nesse amigo eu vim
prestar atenção numa coisa quando as
pessoas termina o namoro que a pessoa
termina o namoro ela tem que dar aquela
animação imbecil que dá na pessoa que a
pessoa termina o namoro ela quer mostrar
para todo mundo que ela tá muito bem Epa
como é que tá rapaz eu tô bem tô bem
bicho fiquei sabendo terminou o namoro
com a mina lá e tal com a menina que eu
tava Ah que eu tava não essa que eu tava
namorando essa última agora de cinco
anos de namoro ou besteira e a pessoa
ela insiste em querer mostrar para você
que ela tá bem deixa eu fazer o seguinte
bora pra festa vamos embora pra festa
vai ter vai ter João Neto Moreira Forró
do cheira mole vai ser massa demais
vamos embora macho de Vieira ficar em
casa mano descansar um pouco tu vai ver
mas eu vou pegar essas gatas tudinho
tudinho para